faire du badminton le sport scolaire le
plus pratiqué en martinique en france et
dans le monde
tel est l'objectif affiché de ce
programme ils sont moniteurs encadrants
sportifs ou même professeur des écoles
ils viennent ici apprendre à apprendre
ce jeu du volant attention bien payé
pour être bien sûr pour armelle c'est
une découverte mais elle y voit déjà
plaint davantage pour les petits élèves
de son école
c'est déjà la coopération c'est la
maîtrise de soi c'est maîtriser ses
émotions ses impulsions savoir ce cadre
et respecter des règles
enfin c'est un peu comme à l'école mais
avec un aspect du dic enfin qu'on a
parce que l'enseignant maternelle car
l'objectif est bien d'initier la
discipline ou plus jeunes
et dès la primaire l'équipement est
simple et peu encombrant après ce stage
les kits seront mises à la disposition
des établissements qui en feront la
demande
ici on ne prône pas la compétition mais
la mise en avant de certaines valeurs
tant sportives que sociales séparées
sport qui traumatise ans il n'y a pas de
contact et de se mélanger avec les
copains de jouer avec les copains mais
aussi les copines mais c'est le sport
qui mélange tout donc la coordination
générale mais aussi donc le physique
parce qu'on fait des sauts on fait des
fautes mais il ya aussi la stratégie est
aussi la technique agilité aptitude à
sauter à lancer a réceptionné
coordination stabilité équilibre les
programmes d'éducation physique qui
retrouve toutes ses qualités à
développer
qu'il pleuve qu'il vente on peut faire
du badminton si on a un espace couvert
donc c'est déjà un avantage l'autre que
l'autre avantage c'est que c'est un
sport où très rapidement un enfant se
retrouve en situation de jeu ludique ses
propres enfants de moins de 12 ans c'est
à dire l'apprentissage par le jeu
donc effectivement c'est une activité
qui s'y prête bien on apprend à faire
des jongles avec les raquettes c'est un
peu difficile mais ça va
le badminton il est différent les autres
sports il est très rapide mais aussi un
peu physique qu'il est bien sûr souhaité
que cela en quelques heures les enfants
ont fait l'expérience se nomme badminton
facile d'accès avec eux les enseignants
sont devenus de nouveaux tuteurs pour
apprendre la discipline en milieu
scolaire